[Musik]
hey was geht ab und bekommt beim ein
video ja als kurdischer sprache team
hier auf youtube gemacht das wird es in
nächster zeit öfter mal geben allgemeine
meist nicht so einfach mal rein und ich
habe euch im deutschen gefragt ja ich
würde gerne heute abend auch ein video
drehen weil ich morgen nach berlin und
ich bin an ersten besondere in berlin
und da ist natürlich schwer videos zu
drehen
deswegen besser wenn man irgendwas
vorproduziert und voll viele weitgehend
wie jo alex macht doch bitte mal wieder
sind es ich habe auch wenn ich schon auf
daten bekommen das halt leute test über
mich halt auf dieser seite teste dicht
oder test.de gemacht haben wie heißt das
test.de ich würde sagen wir schauen
jetzt mal zusammen rein und mal gucken
was über mich gibt ich mache dann
einfach mal von selbst zu mir und mal
gucken ob ich alles richtig habe oder
als auch zweites keine ahnung ich will
ganz klar sein ich wünsche euch viel
spaß okay ganz kurz noch sorry wenn ihr
in zukunft auch so was hab ich hab das
ja früher schon einmal gemacht hat
einfach mal doch nach oben da genau
jetzt dann sehe ich dass bei tim k
machen wir das projekt schnappe ich weiß
mein laptop und dann legen wir los nur
das ist jetzt einfach mal auf teste
dich.de wie lang ist es her dass ich
nicht mehr auf dieser seite hörst du wir
gehen einfach mal hier unterkategorien
und jetzt gehen wir unter youtube
das gibt's ja gar nicht gemacht der
coolste steht sofort im anfang
alex w ach du scheiße so viele youtuber
gibt es in deutschland aber wie schon
oben erwähnt der coolste muss natürlich
um am anfang stehen das hat auch hier
wie man sieht rein ganz mit dem alphabet
zu tun das ist ein wirklich von der
seite von den administratoren ist das
auf jeden fall so ne weißdorf wie gut
kennst du alexis ja alles das gleiche
wieder zu alex ikeng kollektiv mit
qualität wie viele leute haben uns schon
schluss gemacht
guck mal hier das haben zwei 1200 leute
gespielt 1700 leute 1200 alter dass sie
haben einfach wegen 1829 leute gespielt
als ein foto von mir dabei den fragen
von aisha schöne grüße aus so ich würde
sagen er klicken das mal an ich bin
jetzt um ehrlich zu sein war sehr
gespannt ob ich das alles richtig mache
muss ich ja eigentlich so würde ich
nicht richtig machen
könnte man sich fragen warum ich mich
richtig machen ich bin ja eines der der
mich am besten kennt hoffe ich zumindest
es gibt ja immer kranke personen da
draußen sowie fangen an mit der ersten
frage hat alex eine freundin
das ist ja jetzt das ist jetzt auf jeden
fall sehr schnell zu sagen weil das ist
ja denke ich mal nicht so aktuell wie
schaut's entwickelt am 22 04 2016 und ob
ich jetzt gerade aktuelle freundin habe
das weiß natürlich keiner auf ich mir
kurz beiseite ich will jetzt einfach mal
sagen ich war ja vor ungefähr als 2004
und 2006 dann hatte ich eine freundin
deswegen kreuzen wir hier mal ja am auch
wenn das jetzt nicht mehr so aktuell ist
heute ganz ehrlich ihr müsst auf jeden
fall neue quiz über mich erstellen
schick mir lieb und wie gesagt in der
bock hab auch noch mehr teile dann gucke
ich mal was da noch so alles erstellt
und vielleicht ist nicht alles so wie
gut kennt fleximer guck mal da
vereinzelt nur wir gehen hier runter wie
als ist er 19 20 15 23 17
er habe sich ganz klar ich bin 23 die
meisten wissen uns von euch
wahrscheinlich ich bin aktuell so wie
groß ist er 180 170 160 170 ich bin ganz
glas 160 180 habe ich dann schon öfter
mal gesagt ich bin 180 zumindest wenn
ich schwanger bin ich 180 wenn ich schon
hab sonst recht 1 970 aber wenn schwan
hat dann halt nicht und ich habe ja
meistens ganz gut hier
das sind die neuen die sind absolut geil
sie gibt es jetzt für 4000 euro also
wenn ihr die haben wollt schickt einfach
bei inform bild davon und wir gucken wir
uns einig werden allerdings gebohrte
bitte erst noch zwei 3000 euro darunter
kann ich nicht gehen wo sorry welche
augenfarbe hat er ganz klar habe ich
braun die fünfte frage wo wohnt alex das
ist jetzt wirklich sehr schwer zu sagen
und das ist ja gar nicht mehr aktuell
ist voll scheiße also vor einem jahr wo
das ungefähr erstellt wurde habe ich
heute noch in der nähe von bielefeld
gewohnt und aktuell wohne ich in köln
ich bin aber ab morgen in berlin
wenn ihr das video schaut also wenn ihr
auch aus berlin kommt ich bin im hotel
die sechste frage wieso nennt er jedes
mädchens schon teil
ach du scheiße so nennt sie die
technischen teil bei der dynamik schon
toll und cool findet weil der name nicht
gut ist weil es den namen schon
teilmarkt antwort eins und drei komplett
das gleiche für auch zwei sachen
angriffen
wenn ich nehme einfach das erste weiter
den namen schon toll ganz cool findet so
hat sie ihm was marc alexa mädchenaugen
pro charakter aus den brüsten ist doch
logisch dass ich alles mag nur ich kann
ja nicht alles auswählen guckt mal leute
ich will ehrlich sein ich sag immer so
das aussehen ist schon ziemlich wichtig
der charakter ist natürlich auch wer war
superwichtig
aber wenn man sein vater nicht attraktiv
findet dann kannst du auch nicht mit dem
zusammen sein und da kann mir auch
keiner sagen ich habe mich in den korb
doch verliebt alles klar
oh mein gott alles spielt so
oberflächlich mir wenn du da etwas
anderes angegeben hat dann kennst du
mich anscheinend besser als ich mich
selber aber das macht er es wie viele
videos seht alex pro woche auf youtube
hoch gar keins ein video vorwoche zwei
videos pro woche drei videos pro woche
also zwei ist wirklich viel zu wenig ich
lade ja eigentlich mindestens drei
videos vom bauhof aus der letzte woche
da war ich halt im urlaub dagegen nur
einmal das war das trotzdem 2 obwohl ich
im urlaub habe ich zwei videos rausgehen
wenn ich nicht gesehen habt ihr auf
jeden fall an sind mega mega cool
geworden ich wäre es einfach mal drei
videos vorwoche wie lange macht alle
youtube circa zwei jahre zirka drei
jahre zirka vier jahre da das ganze jahr
her ist circa zwei jahre ganz klar an
welchen tagen kostet alles kleine videos
[Musik]
das macht ja gar keinen sinn wenn du
hier die antwort gibt drei videos pro
woche und anschriften montag und
donnerstag sonntag und mittwoch dienstag
und freitag montag und samstag dann
müssen es jetzt zwei videos die woche
sein was aber nicht stimmt man ganz
ehrlich als ich oder wie auch immer das
finde ich nicht gut
da hätte ich auf jeden fall ein bisschen
besser informieren könnt main spazieren
dank für die mühe gemacht dass uns sowas
es steht also zurzeit dienstags
donnerstags freitags und sonntags
meistens hoch da ich aber immer schon
sonntags hochadel würde ich jetzt war
sonntag und mittwoch tippen weil es das
einzige ist was für mich hier logisch
klingt weil ich habe früher auch schon
immer sonntags hochgeladen nur irgendein
tag fehlt halt noch ohne spaßig traum
jetzt gar nicht auf auswertungen zu
klicken
weil nach hersteller du hast vier von
zehn davon richtig und ist richtig
schlecht
ob die augen zu und durch 321 kuka nicht
hin
wie gut die haben zehn von sie haben
sieben von zehn aufgaben richtig
beantwortet im durchschnitt haben die
2373 körperliches gemacht haben 4,8
richtige antworten gegeben
4,8 von 10 ihr seid ihr richtig schlecht
wie sehr interessiert 2373 und eben
schon da 7000 irgendwas sieben von zehn
aufgaben per kopf ich kann mich an
keinen selber nicht perfekt das hat doch
auch ist doch cool so obwohl eigentlich
auch nicht naja ich bin gespannt was sie
mir noch dritte gewisses zukommt hast
einfach aber ins das netzwerk einfach
mal kurz ein kleines leiterin sondern
schickt mir das da am besten mal am
besten halt über instanzen kommt morgen
eventuell neues video wenn anhalt um 14
uhr ich muss schauen ob ich zeit ich
schaffe weil ich mich zu tun auf die
nächsten tage aber weiterhin auch einen
schönen tag
wir sind uns